will it be sleek chic bride or will it
be super romantic pretty princess that
is exactly what I was trying to decide
I've been so lucky that I've been able
to wear so many amazing designers and
dresses on the red carpet but I'm like I
don't even know what my style is cuz
like I love so many different things so
I don't have no idea Julianne Hough may
still have to pick a wedding dress but
she's already planning a family with
fiance Brooks like you aren't kids I've
won a kid since I was like 5 years
absolutely absolutely a lot I mean I
said that I wanted like 4 kids and then
like I'm sure it'll go down like 3 when
like that happens and then when I have
the 1 I'll be like okay two and then
I'll be like okay I'm done
and we'll her brother Derek soon be
following in her footsteps looks like
he's kind of gotten your bug and he
might be in love too no I don't know I
can't say anything about my brother cuz
he's losing fear right now and he would
kill me recently Derek's been linked to
Hayley uber a troupe member on Dancing
with the Stars and Hayley even toured
with Julianne and Derek do you like her
though she was on your tour sweet girl I
don't even know how to say anything I
love her something else Julianne is
loving her role with hashtag thanks
teach a new campaign that raises a
million dollars for public schools most
teachers literally are paying like five
hundred dollars out of their own pocket
just for school supplies I actually was
really fortunate and grateful that I had
amazing teachers and they were the part
of school that I think made my my
experience better as a kid you know and
and the fact that they inspired me to do
what I do today so will Julian ever
bring that inspiration back to the
ballroom on Dancing with the Stars
what's the chances you come back
mixtures I know you're still watching
this I am yeah for sure I mean who knows
I love the show I love being
or the family but I still really want to
focus on my personal career and you know
focus on film and television well if
we're being like a judge on a scale of 1
to 10 and you had your little card you
had to flip what would you flip up if I
said is Julian coming back vixx's I
think it is like a 50/50 thing I don't
know